all right so we're taking a look at
breaching clear deadlines the title MIT
Revit studios it's a spin-off of our
last title breaching clear on mobile all
right so this is the start of our second
hub area it's the park outside of the
city so in the last breaching clear was
a lot more based in reality you know
that it was only against human enemies
you were at different locations around
the globe but there were small maps and
you know each encounter was hang crafted
when we started when we first released
the game on early access we didn't have
any of those handcrafted encounters and
we really felt like the game was it
didn't feel like a breach and clear game
it felt more like a twin-stick shooter
and we really wanted to stick away from
that here we see there's a new enemy
type here known as the breeder he's full
of other worms and he'll revive enemies
as long as he's still alive so he's a
good idea to take out first so that was
one of the big big responses we got from
early access was that it didn't feel
like a breach and clear game and in
adding the real-time control to
deadlines as well as the zombie enemies
you know we wanted to have a little bit
more fun with it you know we still
wanted to keep the pillars that made
breaching clear what it was which was
the real world gear and equipment and
weapons and also the emphasis on tactics
as opposed to just running and gunning
that you see in some games we partnered
with manufacturers and had dealings with
real military outfits when developing
breaching clear the original to make
sure that it felt authentic and based in
reality so with this one we still have
you know covering your angles covering
your corners which was a big part of the
original game which is where the vision
cones come in as you move around you
know having a squad of four men was
important to us so we feel we feel like
we we struck a good balance between
fantasy and reality so here now we'll
see that where we've got our first
encounter with human enemies here
they're holed up in this diner
so first I'm going to move my squad into
a closer position so I can take a better
look around
so this is where tactics and flanking
and covering corners will be a lot more
important than it was against the zombie
characters since they can fire back now
so first we see we've got some some
mercenary snipers here as there those
can be pretty dangerous so I'm gonna use
my pin ability to pin this guy in place
and then move them around the side
afterwards going to use this class over
here to tag both of them so they'll take
more damage and then move him around the
side as well as I move the rest of my
squad in position to fire
all right so they're down so now
particularly close to look we're in
command mode everything's paused we can
see we've got a pretty good stronghold
in there and we've also got a walk-in
freezer full of full of zombies there
that are stuck in there so now we could
clear everyone out open up that door and
kill them but instead I'm gonna try and
use them to my advantage to help me take
care of some of the human enemies in
there so much like in a real world
location that has multiple entrances
you'll find that in a lot of the
buildings in the game as well so we say
we've got a back door into the kitchen
the front door here and a side door as
well so I'm gonna continue to move my
squatter on the back
so looking inside what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna take one of my men open this
door now there's some there's some
mercenaries in here that have been that
are gonna be alerted as I walk in
somebody's go to my inventory and I'm
gonna use this hornet's nest here which
is basically a glorified flashbang that
that has a longer effect
I might toss that in there open this
door open that door
let those actions play out so they're
stunned now open that door
that door open doing my inventory again
grab a signal flare
toss it into the main the main area and
run back out now that he's safely
outside I'm gonna switch to squad
control moving back around the front of
the diner as you can see the zombies are
now gonna help me take out some of the
squad members of the the enemy
mercenaries so I'm gonna send my close
quarters guys up to the front my
longer-range to the side yes sir
now that everyone's in position and have
my team breach and clear this diner
now the doors are open and move my team
of the position
yes sir
yes
we use a Molotov here to help me clear
out this zombie group over by the
kitchen
see we're getting some enemies coming in
from the side here's some of the tags
some of them so they can take some more
damage
stitch garden
just throw a frag grenade over there for
good measure
it's not I can regroup on the front here
take out the remaining enemies let me
use my pen ability again in this large
breeder and then activate his exploit
weakness ability so do two times the
damage for the next five seconds and a
flashbang for good measure so now my
squad takes care of them I'm gonna
switch to some real time to get my hands
dirty
thanks for checking out breaching clear
deadlines we have a full release on July
21st we're still in early access if you
want to check it out early hope you
enjoy the game